for the first time China's space agency
has launched a civilian astronaut into
orbit
the shinzhou 16 spacecraft took off with
a three-person crew from a launch site
in Northwest China they will conduct
experiments at the Tian gong space
station where the crew is expected to
stay for five months all astronauts on
previous Chinese missions have been part
of China's Army
well Colin Baker has more on the
country's space achievements so far
China is already a force in space but
that requires continued space science
the country landed a Rover on Mars in
2021 joining only the Soviet Union and
the United States to have done so but
the moon offers a practical base for
space exploration and China has several
missions already the Changi Lander
returned a sample from the surface in
2020. the first time that had been done
in half a century it revealed one of the
places water might be found on the moon
in tiny glass beads which could be
useful information for future missions
now China runs one of only two places
that humans can live in orbit the Tian
gong space station onboard astronauts
are measuring how their bodies react to
weightlessness and how to keep fit
critical first steps to long-term
missions there are experiments on how
plants grow how combustion Works in Low
Gravity how materials can endure the
harsh effects of outer space and an
onboard supercomputer and high-speed
data transmission system to the ground
China is already preparing to take the
lead in space along with those who may
partner with it
let's get more from Katrina you in
Beijing and Katrina how significant is
this latest launch for China and what
does it mean for its Space Program
well this has been hailed as a complete
success by the Chinese government of
Beijing has lauded it as a milestone
indeed it's the first time that China
has sent a civilian that's a
non-military officer up into space his
name was guay is guay Hai Chao he's a
university Professor who will be
performing the role as payload expert on
board the shendo 16. now that rocket was
launched from the China's inner Mongolia
Province at 931 local time on Tuesday
altogether there are three men on board
and they will join an existing
three-person crew onboard the China
space station the Tian gong and all
together they will perform one orbit
rotation Mission before that previous
team returns to earth and the shendo 16
team will stay on board until November
now during that time what's going to
keep them busy is general maintenance
tasks they will perform a few spacewalks
and specifically they are tasked with
forming science experiments in the areas
of quantum physics relativity and
space-time
Katrina how does the Chinese program
compare to what we see in the Western
World what are the ultimate aims and
Ambitions of the Chinese going forward
well during this launch we saw crowds
watching it from afar they were waving
Chinese flags and cheering this program
is a huge source of national pride and
China has invested billions into it and
it has remained a priority even
throughout the pandemic and despite the
fact that China's economy is slowing
it's also a source of soft power China
has the only space station that's
orbiting now that's completely run by
its own government the only other space
station is the International Space
Station which is much bigger and much
older but will be decommissioned over
the next few years now China has major
Ambitions when it comes to space they
announced on Monday that they will aim
to put a man on the Moon by the year
2030 and the Tian gong the space station
that was completed at the end of last
year is a big part of that plan they
also have plans to have space tourists
to visit that space station and
eventually foreign astronauts also work
on board now there are some concerns
that China's space program is heavily
linked to its military a tree and the
advancements of China's PLA and that
might present some obstacles when it
comes to collaborating with other
countries indeed the United States has
this security concern and in 2011 they
enacted their own law preventing NASA
from working with China's space program
but experts say ironically this law that
the U.S enacted has served to only
accelerate China's development in the
space field okay thank you so much that
is Katrina you for us in Beijing
Quentin Parker is director of the
laboratory for space research at Hong
Kong University he says civilian
astronauts expand the ability for more
research and space
the space station is basically a huge
laboratory and it's a laboratory that's
going to be increasingly filled with a
variety of experiments and Technologies
from around the world and so that is
intended to um you know so that the
reason why there's a civilian is a
civilian is a scientist an academic and
you need somebody with the skill and the
experience and the knowledge of how to
operate maintain you know delicate
equipment and that can't be done with
people usually from military background
but China is is getting on board with
its own independent missions uh to not
just create its own space station have
its own quite uh ambitious Space Program
more generally but also to go back to
the moon for our future exploration
purposes exploitation perhaps of the
resources including water interestingly
there's been mentionings if you look at
Hunt around at the 10 years from now
there's going to be tourists on the
Chinese space station and by then who
knows how large it will be because
already the original configuration is
complete but they've just done announced
they're going to be adding another major
node module to the Chinese space station
and the cross pattern so 90 degrees to
the plane of the current alignment of
the Chinese space station are going to
put another big module in that's going
to have many docking ports and you can
keep adding to it I mean just like the
International Space Station grew over a
long period of time the current version
of China is only about 25 the size of
the ISS ISS and so this is going to
enable that Chinese space station to do
more to carry out more experiments to
have more crew on board to do new things